say hi hi anything you want to say happy
birthday wow
true crashes her mom Khloe Kardashian's
workout we all want to be cute over here
okay and two days
no two weeks for uh spring break two
weeks
thank you the four-year-old who's
excited about spring break counts down
the days my favorite part about being a
mom I mean it's so corny but it's just
complete Bliss yeah I was unable to take
true to school because I have work I
start Glam at nine so I can't make it so
I'm working out a little later which
feels so good yeah and while the little
one plays hooky from school with Mom
Coco goes beast mode in the gym let's
get to it
I wake up when I go to the gym and I
work on Fitness and just healthy like
even your mental you have to practice
that you have to that's a workout in
itself Chloe's latest workout video
comes as the Kardashians prepare to kick
off season three of their Hulu reality
Series in May I wish I could tell you
this is going to be a mild relaxing
Serene season
it's not it was definitely very angry
and I think feeling
Bamboozled season two wasn't quite
peaceful either Coco's drama with extras
and Thompson played out front and center
we did an embryo transfer like days
before Thanksgiving and I found out
about Tristan's situation the first week
of December I mean it's supposed to be a
really exciting amazing time and it's
just
a different experience I think I just
felt bad for her
that
it the joy was kind of sucked out of it
again you know but ETS learned Chloe and
Tristan are in a good place now as they
continue to co-parent their two kids
including their eight-month-old son
whose name has yet to be revealed
no name Johnson over here
[Music]
a source tells ET she isn't in love with
Tristan but she chooses to be supportive
both publicly and privately for the sake
of their children I think everyone has
to handle their co-parenting situation
in their own style but my mom and my dad
were like that it took them years but my
dad would come over once a week for
family dinners and would play golf with
my stepdad and so we come from a family
where we believe in that and you share
children with people and that's how it
should be
[Music]
foreign